يقول علماء في جامعه كوبنهاجن ان دراستهم
حول الجلد الاصطناعي تهدف الى معرفه ما
يحدث عندما تصبح الخلايا الطبيعيه سرطانيه
العلماء بحثوا في مسار اشارات تطلقه خلايا
تسمى مسار كي جي اف بيتا يلعب المسار دورا
في كيفيه التواصل الخلايا مع محيطها
والتحكم في نمو الخلايا وانقسامها اذا
تعطلت هذه الاليات تصبح الخليه سرطانيه
وتغزو الانسجه المحيطه في الظروف العاديه
لا تغزو خلايا الجلد الطبقه تحت الجلد
انها تكون طبقه جديده ولكن مع ظهور
الخلايا السرطانيه تبدا في الغزو وتظهر في
النهايه او تظهر في النهايه سلوكا يسمى
النمو الغازي العلماء درسوا هذا المسار
وطبقوا اساليب مختلفه لوقف هذا النمو
الخبيث وبالفعل وجدوا العديد من الادويه
تستطيع سد هذه المسارات وبعضها كايد البحر
[موسيقى]